alright we're going to get started and
we're going to keep this pretty chill
she just asked questions if you want and
there's like no no equations and up code
and it's pretty I know it's a lot of
talk of the day so we're going to keep
it pretty pretty loose we're going to be
talking about a puppet called finder
there can be two of us or gonna like tag
team it just to tell us you a little bit
about who we are my name is Jeremy
Freeman and this is andrew otra and I
run a neuroscience research group and
our lab sort of does full-stack
neuroscience so everything from like
crazy experiments to date analysis of
visualization sort of everything in
betray now we're called the Fremen lab
and we're at this really cool nonprofit
research institute in virginia sorry
nonprofit research institute in virginia
and this is what it looks like it's on a
lake and it's really high tech and
really futuristic and it was recently
pointed out to us that this place which
is called genelia looks a lot like
Starfleet Academy this is from the one
where they have to save the whales um if
anyone remembers that movie so what's
going on how can I use that oh sweet
okay great this is better ok cool so
this is where we work sorry not that we
work with the other one I wish we worked
at the Starfleet Academy it sort of
feels like that sometimes I also want to
give a bunch credit to a lot of other
people who are not the two of us but
have been really influential in this
project in brittle in particular Kyle
Kelly who built what really we view is
the sort of predecessor to this and also
a bunch of other people like Sophia min
and Peter have been really influential
either in the form of ideas or code or
some combination of the two so I want to
tell you basically the story for this
project and sort of why why we did it
and where it came from and the starting
point which is I guess the starting
point for a lot of things is we're
brains and that's because we studied
neuroscience and in particular we do a
lot of kind of crazy experiments that
result in a lot of complicated data and
there's a lot of complicated stuff we
have to do with that data so to give you
a sense of what those experiments are
like here's an example from a incredibly
talented postdoc Nick sophronia of who's
working both with me and also with Carl
sobota
which is another experimental group and
Genelia so the way these experiments
work is that we have mice and the mice
are running on these little balls and
that's we were seeing on the left and
what we're doing with the mice is
simulating a tactile virtual environment
so mice are really tactile animals they
spent a lot of their time basically
thinking about their whiskers and using
their whiskers to explore the world so
what this system has our walls on either
side of the mouse and the walls move
back and forth to touch them animals
whiskers to simulate its experience of
running through a corridor and the idea
is you know basically think like oculus
but with walls to make the animal think
that it's inside of little quarter and
running around and exploring
environments so the reason we're going
through all the trouble of simulating a
tactile virtual environment is that we
want the animals to be stationary so we
can record brain activity and that's
what the image on the right shows so
there are these methods called calcium
imaging tool called calcium imaging
where we use two-photon microscopy to
literally monitor the activity of
neurons in the form of light these
animals are transgenic ly engineered so
that their neurons literally light up
when they're active and we can see that
in the form of a picture like the one
I'm showing on the right so basically
simultaneously to having the animals
Explorer complex environments while they
are not actually moving we can record
brain activity we can also stimulate
neural activity so we can turn neurons
on and we can turn ron's off and do all
this in order to understand how this
little animals brain figures out where
it is processes sensory information
figures out where it is in the world so
this is the kind of work we do this is
the kind of research we do and as you
can imagine this generates a lot of data
in a variety of forms whether it's like
the animal's behavior or the images that
we generate and we as a group and really
is i think as a field care a lot about
doing this in the open we want to make
our data available we want to make our
analysis available whether it's to
collaborate better with other scientists
or to sort of collaborate and
communicate what we're doing to the
world around us it's a really important
part of science that we make it open in
public so that raises a challenge which
is how do we take these data and the
analysis of these data and sort of put
basically put that on the internet like
how do we make all of that available in
public everybody
so that's sort of a question that we
have been asking ourselves a lot and
we're asking ourselves a lot and we
already try really hard to use open
source technologies so we do a lot of
the analysis of these data using things
like Python we do a lot with the Jupiter
notebook which i think is a great format
for building kind of documents that
include analysis and visualization all
together and as a way to communicate
that information but we still need a way
to kind of like put it online basically
so that other people can take what we've
done and run the same analyses or maybe
try their own analyses on the data that
we were analyzing those are the kinds of
things we want to enable so when we
started think about how to do that there
was one really exciting way to
potentially do that that was floating
around called temp mb does anyone here
how many people here have heard of or
use time to be okay oh wow awesome great
so I don't really have to explain too
much about the details but suffice to
say temp mb is a system originally
developed by kyle kelly as well as min
and others as part of the Jupiter team
and the idea is basically to use
technologies like docker to build and
generate reproducible environments so we
thought that was super cool when we saw
it and we're like oh this would be a
great way to put online the kinds of
things we're doing and to build
reproducible environments so we did that
in the form of this project called oh
call bank of america that's cool
interesting yeah bank of america it's
really fun working on it we've made a
lot of money i think the bank is doing
really well we do a lot of interesting
analysis like users and they spend money
and then we have to talk about it yay
does that work though teresting I'll try
this again no I fine if this doesn't
load I oh there we go okay cool I'm not
going to demo this but basically we put
together this website as part of an
organization we run called code neuro
which is this meetup to try to bring
together neuro scientists and data
scientists you should all check it out
code nerd org and as part of code neuro
we build a website where we basically
put together a bunch of Jupiter
notebooks and some data sets that we're
trying to share and some code and
analyses we're trying to demo and we put
it all together in a temp and be so that
anyone could click that launch button
and immediately be dropped into an
environment in which they could
basically do all the same kind of stuff
that we're doing with our data all the
time and we're really excited about this
it seems really cool and we we had fun
making it I think people enjoyed using
it we used it to set up things like
benchmarking competitions where we like
we get a bunch of neuroscientist I'll
try to analyze the same data really
valuable we don't do enough of that but
then we wanted to do it again so we like
wrote some new library or we generate
some other data set or we had some other
project and we're like going to be cool
if we could do what we just did a temp
and beans do it all over again so we did
do it all over again we had to build a
system and set up a server and put
together the docker images and go
through all this stuff it was kind of
complicated but we did it and then we
want to do it again and then we want to
do it again and basically it became
really time consuming to try to put
together these temp mb deployments and
the fact that we were doing this over
and over Iwo something sorry I'm chill
okay the fact that we were doing this
over and over again led us to believe
that probably other people were trying
to do the same thing it might be
interested in doing the same thing over
and over again so that was sort of the
state of things and we started wonder
like what if we could take any github
repository that has notebooks and some
other stuff and then turn that into an
environment immediately with like one
button that anybody could then launch
and be dropped into the same
reproducible environment and that was
kind of our goal we were unsure how to
do it and feeling a little bit unsure
about how hard it would be but then I
had a beer with Fernando Perez because I
was visiting him at Berkeley so if you
ever want like inspiration and life you
should talk to either Fernando or Brian
they're just incredibly inspirational
people certainly they are for me and
basically I have this really great
conversation with Fernando and we are
talking about it the fact is to be
really cool and in particular somebody I
don't want to credit this to anyone in
particular but somebody pointed out that
the combination of github repositories
and notebooks could basically be a
torpedo aimed at academic publishing and
I for one feel that academic publishing
leases it exists right now is really
doing a disservice to science and we
need to replace it with something better
and it may be something like github
repos and notebooks could be a path in
that direction if it was made really
easy and reproducible so that got me
excited because I love taking down
academic publishing and I'm happy to say
that on video I guess so basically we
decided to build a prototype of what
this kind of thing would look like and
in particular the thing that Fernando
said while we're having a beer he was
like what if you just had a badge in
your github repo that if you clicked on
it it would be like a run me in a
virtual environment that was sort of you
know fern and it was like you could
probably do that that'd be cool so
that's what we tried to do and
apparently the Wi-Fi in this building
has really been really bad so we made a
walkthrough of a little demo of us using
this thing called binder this was just
pre recorded earlier today it's not
staged but I don't want to rely on the
Wi-Fi so I'm just gonna walk you through
what this looks like and this is all on
the just my binder or website so the
idea is that if you go to this website
you can tell us a github repository I'm
just going to play this video and I'll
narrate it as I go so to pretend I'm
like at my computer so the first thing
we do is just specify a github
repository and this is going to be a
repository that contains your notebooks
in your code and the stuff you want to
be able to reproduce and then you just
tell us what kind of dependencies you
have we're going to go through this in
more detail and then you click make and
now you get to see the Domino's Pizza
Tracker on the left and logs in the
middle and what we're doing is basically
building an environment for you that
contains everything you told us you need
from your github repository including
your Jupiter notebooks and any
specifications of the kind of
dependencies you have and we're building
it I know it's going to work is this is
pre-recorded but it always works even if
it's not pre-recorded and we build this
whole thing up we bundle it up we do a
bunch of magic that enters going to tell
you about in just a second and then it
is a thing that you can now have anybody
launched by clicking that little button
on the right so that little button is
something you can now in bed and your
github repo in this little launch binder
button and then when anyone goes to this
page and goes to this repository clicks
button they are now dropped into an
environment that is exactly the
environment you specified and now
everybody can do this and basically run
your tutorials or your demos or whatever
exactly as you originally intended it so
it's basically just closing the gap
between the environment you want to give
people to run and their ability to be
dropped into or to have people you want
to share your environment with be
dropped into it so here the only
dependency was Seaborn and as I'm sure
you can appreciate we're generating
plots whiskey born so if that all looked
a little bit magical I'm going to tag
out and give it to andrew who can tell
you what actually just happened hey cool
hmm so edit score binder is a system for
taking dependencies taking codeine
dependencies that are stored somewhere
and converting them into something that
you can then deploy very easily on a
cluster and access just through any any
web browser and really the point of this
slide is to show that most of binder
that there are a few core components of
binder and each one of these are is
really just a small modification or a
very simple wrapper around existing open
source technology so there are a number
of projects or really indebted to it has
really made this whole thing possible
and so I'll just sort of go through the
various components and and what we do in
them so in the in the first phase we
want to take some sort of an environment
some sort of a description of an
environment and then convert it into an
object that we can then run very easily
somewhere and docker is a technology
that does exactly that and from the
number of you that are familiar with
temp and be I'm sure most of you
probably familiar with docker two so
what doctor does is it is it takes a
description of an environment and this
configuration file called a docker file
and the dockerfile has a sequence of
commands in it and each one of those
commands is executed and you sort of
gradually build up this this image of
this environment and this is really
perfect for us so the first step we do
is we take code and we bundle it into a
docker file but then we sort of face the
problem of well we're running these
darker files for lots of different users
and we need some sort of a system to be
able to say but how these docker file
should be run on a cluster and managed
so for example which ones can
communicate with which other ones and
what resources should they all have and
this is a really a space that's growing
really rapidly and we chose to use this
cool project called Cooper Nettie's
which is an open source project that
out of Google in the past year for doing
just this and it gives gives us just a
whole number of really great
abstractions and concepts for working
with containers and deployments on a
cluster and it's been really useful for
us and then of course once we have these
environments we need some sort of an
interface for communicating with them
and it was always the goal of this
project to use the Jupiter notebook for
that and I'm sure most of you have used
the notebook it's just a very great
interactive web-based environment for
for running Python or running any code
depending on which kernels that use very
easily so now that I've sort of
described the the various technologies
that we use I'll sort of just do a
step-by-step through the different
phases of the of the binder process so
the first phase that we have is just
taking code and converting it into this
image and so what we do is you can go to
the main binder page that you saw in
that video and you can you point it to a
repository and you also select from a
set of dependency files that we
currently support so right now we only
support a couple we support a
requirement select txt file for pip and
then an environment diambil file for
Conda and if these don't suit your needs
then you can always go into sort of
hardcore mode and specify the darker
value file yourself and we will take
these and then for each one we will look
at the file and we have just a known set
of commands that we're going to then
sort of insert into a docker file as we
generate the stalker file and then we're
going to build this this sort of primary
image these blue circles here and these
blue circles are really just the core of
binder these are all did the doctor
images well sir there's a one-to-one
mapping between a repository and one of
these primary images and this really
gets us most of the way there but it's
not ideal for certain cases so you can
imagine having something like a database
which you want to configure but you
don't really need to configure it in any
app specific way so like there's no
information in the repository that you
need to configure the database you just
want to have something you can connect
to and then to start dumping data into
but what you could do is you could write
a custom docker file for doing just that
but that's really not recommended
because you just get these massive
bloated monolithic docker files that are
really hard to work with so instead what
we give you is this idea of an external
service and these are these the pink and
purple circles there and what an
external service is it something that
you can configure
side of the app build process and we
will pre-build images for these and then
when you want to deploy these on the
cluster we will just kind of will deploy
new containers for those services and
then just dynamically attach them to the
the main notebook image that we have and
in order to do this we have this
template file which specifies which main
image you want to use and also which
external service images you want to use
as well as some other metadata that you
might have and the idea really behind
these template files is we want to keep
them very back-end agnostic so so really
right now we're using Cooper Nidhi's is
our main cluster but you can imagine
deploying these template files on on
various different backends including
locally for for testing there so finally
in the in the next phase we want to do
is we want to take these in our case
right now the only one we support is
Cooper need ease but we want to take
these template files and somehow
transform them into a set of n
containers that's running on a Cooper
Nettie's cluster and just are going a
little bit of detail about how that
works crew benitez just gives us these
great concepts we're doing exactly that
so there's the idea of a pod which is a
set of like a set of n co-located
containers that are all running on one
note of a cluster and then there also
other concepts like services which tell
you how to reference these pods
regardless of where they're scheduled on
the clothes on the cluster so you could
just you type in one name like spark
master and that will route you to
whichever pod the spark master is
actually running in so we use these
services and we just translate a
template file into a crew bernetti
specific description of pods and
services and a few other things and and
then we have our our deployment running
on the contagious cluster yeah ok so the
question was what are the most common
external services and what we do is we
have to sort of hand write those for now
eventually we want to sort of break
those out in two separate modules for
writing services but now we only support
on the Postgres database and and spark
so you attach spark to it and what we'll
do is whenever you deploy a binder we
will launch a master and a worker
alongside it and what's really cool
about that actually is um is because
Kuber dd's also gives us this idea of a
replication controller which says you
can scale up the number of replicas of a
container that you want so you could you
know we could attach a replication
controller to the worker and just
sort of crank up a knob and you'll
actually just see parallelism right
there listen your number of workers
increase so it's a very natural thing to
be able to do so now that I've sort of
gone through those stages all I'll talk
a little bit about the state of the
cluster as it is right now so everything
is running on Google compute engine and
it's all running on on ten just pretty
pretty small nodes so we we right now
give you slots we're the right now 400
slots for running binders and this is
kind of an arbitrary number we haven't
really pushed it yet but we've gotten
kind of close and we're seeing you know
somewhere in the range of about 200
deployments per day so we imagine that
adds demand increases we will increase
the number of slots here too but if you
want to check in and see how many are
available you can go to our status page
and hopefully it should always say
binder service is running and that
should be green and when that's not
green them very sad so so you can go to
the site and check that out there we
also recently added this visualization
which lets you see all the binders that
have been built and all the ones that
are currently running so on the left all
these blue circles are ones that have
been built and there are about 300 that
have been built so far and you could
just kind of explore these and check
them out there are some really cool ones
somebody ported their entire machine
learning text book into a binder which
has been really fun they're also like
you know really cool audio demos in the
notebook and geospatial analyses it's
just it's really fun you can spend a
whole evening just playing with them and
on the right here we have the ones that
are currently running on the cluster so
you could just see what people are doing
there's one that's really popular right
now compared to the other ones yeah it's
a nice way to see just what what's
currently happening in wonderland and
and finally we have we have this unique
opportunity working with binder to be
able to run analyses over all the ones
that have been built and just see what
people really want and what people are
doing so we right now this is yeah this
this analysis was run over 287 binders
and we saw that the vet almost half of
them really didn't need to specify any
dependency files and they were
completely satisfied with what we
provide in the base image so in our base
image which is the image that all
binders are built on top of we we
provide anaconda and either people are
satisfied with that or people are just
you know just kind of gym okay or people
are just kind of play around of binder
and their notebooks I never get it
but you know you could just click make
without selecting any dependencies and
and that and that would lead to also
saying no dependencies but um but the
next most common one is requirements and
and then we have docker file which is a
pretty small percentage of the binders
that have been built and that's that's a
good thing to see because we kind of
want to discourage people from writing
their own docker files and ideally we
want to provide dependency files that
are really easy to understand and really
easy for people to write so that we
never have to have people rightful so
that system specifications in a docker
file people find that to be very
confusing we found and they much prefer
just using an easy to understand a
dependency file that wraps all that
complexity for them and I sit for them
spam can lead to some problems yeah and
also in this in the same vein we also we
also just kind of just yeah we're able
to actually see which dependencies which
packages are popular among people who
use binder as well and this is not
surprising at all so people generally
like to use the things that are packaged
into anaconda and so you could just see
here which ones most people want to use
and this is out of yeah 300 binders that
have been built yeah surprising there
yeah this is all pretty pretty standard
okay um so yeah figure now would be a
good time to sort of address um address
popular questions we have a chat room
where people there's always an active
discussion and there are some questions
that we just get all the time so the
first five farm you know far and away
the most popular question is who's
paying for this and the answer for that
yet now is is the lab it's coming out of
the lab budget but it's really it's just
a couple of notes for now um so it's
that's okay but as it expands well this
would sort natural leads into the next
question which is do intend to
commercialize this and the answer for
that is yeah I definitely know we think
it's really important that it's a free
public service for people to use and so
as it scales up and as it expends we
will do what it takes to sustain that as
an external or if sorry as a free public
service even if yeah if that means
getting external funding then that's
what it means and also the next question
after that is kind
deploy one well what if the public
cluster is just not what I want to use
what if I have sort of stricter
requirements on like certain kinds of
hardware or something and the answer for
that is is of course it's all open
source you can go on github and and
check it out but it's the process is
kind of convoluted right now and we
haven't really tried to make it simple
we've all of our new features have gone
into supporting the public cluster so if
you want to do this I would wait for the
next version that we're currently
working on right now which will be just
far better for deploying your own
private clusters well we'll make that
process far more documented and easier
to work with so these are the
technologies that we're currently using
and binder one point oh but as we move
forward yet there's still a number of
flaws and binder that we really need to
address and there's a bunch of cool new
technologies that we think will be
really well-suited for that so one of
the main problems that we have is
specifying data so people often ask I
have this big data set and I want to use
it from a binder what do I do and the
answer for that right now is kind of
lame so the answer that is either you
can put a limited version of the data
set into github in your repository or
you can oh yeah you can do a custom
docker file option than just like do a
curl in the docker file and load all the
data in but that's not ideal ideally
what you'd want is you would want some
sort of a configuration file where you
could really just have a data field and
just put like some sort of a commit
number some sort of a reference to a
data set at a certain point in time and
this is exactly what that does so that
is basically like get but for data and
so you can use something like this in
some special config file to to to solve
this data problem and we were sort of
exploring the best ways to do that
another thing you could also do with
that or out maybe I go back a little
yeah another thing you could also do
with that is have better persistence for
your notebooks so right now all of your
notebooks are packaged into the same
docker file that your dependencies are
in but you can imagine splitting those
out and then versioning your notebooks
independently and like a separately a
separate version controlled sort of
repository and that'd be really nice a
nice use case for dad as well also no
that's okay yet that also we want so
right now we're currently only using
Cooper Nettie's but we really want to be
able to support a variety of backends so
I mentioned before that this template
specification is designed to be
agnostic of which back-end it's running
on so there are there are a number of
cool new ones that have popped up like
docker swarm and there's no mad which is
another cool one that I haven't really
worked with but I've seen it looks
interesting and we really you know we
don't want binder to be the thing that
decides which one of those is best we
want people to be able to to jump in and
write their own if that's what suits
them so we're looking into ways to to
make it easier to write your own
back-end for binder that will run these
things and in the same vein we will
right now all these computational
environments are only interface through
the Jupiter notebook but there are some
really cool projects right now like like
like Thebe that came out of O'Reilly for
interacting with with Jupiter kernels
that are running on temp and be and
interacting with those through just
little widgets that are embedded in the
browser and this is really interesting
we want minor to be able to do something
like that as well so something that
we're thinking about is sort of a
headless mode binder where where you can
just connect two kernels that are
running in this environment from any
sort of front end the notebook or
something else and that that's something
we're looking into more so yeah if you
can't tell there's a lot to do and we're
currently really working really hard on
on the second version of binder which
which splits up all those various phases
that I mentioned in the earlier diagram
in two different modules that can all be
just independently tested and deployed
and yeah there's a lot of places to jump
in there are tons of issues on the
github page so definitely come come join
us and talk to us in the chat room if
you have any cool ideas or if you want
to contribute open issues and yeah the
book to have conversations about this so
yeah so thanks to you guys for listening
and thanks to everybody you know in the
chat room who is who have contributed
great ideas and on the github page and
yeah just come come join and contribute
so thank you
and these are just at just links that we
reference in the talk if you want to
look at those via any any questions no
no oh yeah yeah it's on the very first
slide yeah yeah any other questions yeah
I think I think yeah I think Jeremy
might be better suited to answer this
question yes there are definitely
overlaps between those those two things
and that space in general is definitely
I would say undergoing a significant
amount of development so dat which I've
started to get to know more and more and
especially get to know the team and
they're incredible people doing really
really exciting things very early on in
its initial stage was focused on tabular
data so they basically wanted a way to
version do sort of get style version
control over basically tables CSV JSON
style data that was going on for about a
year and a half and it was working
pretty well but in the last half year or
year or so they've been trying to
generalize because they had this
realization that if they had a really
good way to do version control over data
a file system is also data and that
would maybe now be a way to also do
version control over file systems and
operating systems which means maybe
they've actually come up with a way to
version environments that's better or
more lightweight than something like
docker so it evolved it is currently
evolving from something just focused on
data version in to basically environment
version in it is definitely in
development and that is obviously an
incredibly complex problem I think they
have really exciting ideas about how to
solve it and they're they're really out
there and doing some cool stuff and
we're excited to find I think a variety
of ways in which we could use it here
simple things would be like what Andrew
talked about just you want to be able to
point to a data set that we pull in to
your environment but if they really
solve the environment problem
in a way that's better and lighter
weight than docker well then we would
use that instead of docker basically so
that's sort of that that is where dad is
a little bit the large flood the github
large file system stuff there was an
article I read recently and I haven't
used it too much but it was a pretty
long discussion of some issues related
to bandwidth constraints so they have
they not only charge you for storage but
also for bandwidth and I believe you
can't fork a repo in terms of if it has
a large file system large file storage
enabled and you're not able to fork the
data that's because they don't want or
you're unable essentially to pay for the
band width that would be required for
that so if you own a repo you
essentially have to pay for a bandwidth
of anybody who is forking that repo are
pulling down that data you know I love
github but that to me seems if that's
true and that's really how it works and
i think that is sort of how it works
that seems kind of broken because that's
a huge part of social coding is forking
right we all do that all the time
Porkins grade so yeah I sort of feel
like in general one wants to sort of
stay tuned about all these things it is
definitely a kind of complex in process
thing sort of my sense other questions
comments yeah you can I mean there's
some so will we put some stuff into the
image that's little binder specifics
right now the default command is inside
the dockerfile is tailored to binder
because we have to access all these all
these notebooks through a proxy it's
actually the same proxy that jupiter hub
uses it's the configurable HTTP proxy
but if you provide your own command you
can you could do it just fine so yeah
people people have been testing locally
and then then pouring it over to binder
any other questions yeah Sarah
sorry saying I mean here's pretty
awesome like a lot of great ideas came
out of here there were my time in two
beers we should probably get a beer
right now yes we all came up with a new
idea that'd be pretty cool we don't have
for not knowing for tonight Brian's here
yeah other question anymore all right
awesome mix it up yeah one more one more
what's it yeah it works but you have to
write your own daughter file for that
but if you write your own and you
install your own kernels yeah works
totally yeah alright thanks guys
you